[Music]
following 2016's couch co-op hit over
cooked to brings a fresh set of kitchens
and recipes to conquer the fun and chaos
of playing with friends is preserved
here as is the far less exciting reality
of playing solo
and while the added online play can't
compare to the in-person version the new
throwing mechanic and a host of
ridiculous kitchen layouts make for a
delightfully frenetic follow-up
[Music]
like the original overcooked two takes
you from one poorly laid out kitchen to
the next tasking you with cooking as
many dishes as possible within a set
time limit whether alone or with friends
each kitchen poses its own set of
problems and hurdles conveyor belts make
basic movement more difficult floating
rafts and hot air balloons cause
kitchens to shift under your feet and
the sink is usually nowhere near the
dirty plates it can be hard to figure
out how to approach each level but it's
very easy for even the best strategies
to devolve into chaos solving problems
is just as fun as failure an overcooked
two still serves both audiences
beautifully nothing about cooking is
simple except for the controls each task
like chopping ingredients or washing
dishes requires a single button the rest
is a balancing act that demands careful
coordination and adaptability with one
partner you'll probably have more
success planning your strategy and put
more mental energy towards juggling
various tasks with the max of four
people a small inconvenience can turn
into a lot of panic yelling and possibly
a fire it's often a comedy of errors and
successfully serving up dishes as a
triumph worth celebrating
[Music]
[Applause]
while much of the basic formula remains
the same overcooked - as the ability to
throw raw ingredients a block of cheese
flying as you're chopping a tomato makes
the kitchen feel more hectic but it's
actually extremely helpful
you can throw chop meat directly into a
frying pan to save time or toss some
fish across a moving platform that's
blocking your path it's a relatively
small addition but it smartly manages to
add to the chaos without
overcomplicating it overcook - also adds
on line play a fine idea that's far less
compatible with the best parts of the
game it's a different kind of challenge
to cook with limited communication
especially on switch thanks to the lack
of built-in voice chat but playing
online lacks the urgency of playing with
people in the same room a bit of lag too
can ruin the flow or cause you to miss
click it's a welcome feature if your
co-op partner is far away though and
better suited for completionists rather
than those looking to goof off playing
alone is also the domain of
completionists as its kind of a chore
you switch between two chefs and it's a
matter of smart tasks management without
the fun of communicating and screwing up
with other people
over cooked to undoubtedly shines and
local co-op and versus arcade modes new
recipes and obstacles provide a fresh
challenge for veterans but it remains
approachable for new players with simple
controls and short play times the new
throwing mechanic - adds a new dimension
to both strategy and the inevitable
chaos without overcomplicating things
it's a strong foundation and with the
right friends over cook - is one of the
best couch co-op games around
[Music]